[Applause]
they've come to help to pick up
relatives and deliver supplies to
Russian occupied areas
and this was how they died
cut down next to their cars or in them
blood pooling among the shattered glass
today at 7 10 Russian troops launched
three missiles at the car market near
the zapparija orikiv highway civilians
trying to cross the checkpoint for the
occupied territory were hit
Russia has denied responsibility and
thrown the accusations back at Ukraine
[Music]
hours after the attack Vladimir Putin
formally annexed four Ukrainian regions
the UN has condemned this as illegal but
the Kremlin put on a patriotic party in
Moscow regardless
president zielinski has been pushed to
respond after meeting defense and
security Chiefs it was his turn for a
big announcement
we are taking our decisive step by
signing Ukraine's application for
Accelerated accession to Nato
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has already
driven Sweden and Finland into NATO's
protection now moscow's big nightmare
Ukraine's membership may happen too but
all 30 NATO countries have to agree
before a new member is admitted and
aspirant Nations have to commit to the
peaceful resolution of any territorial
dispute that's something that Ukraine is
clearly unable to do whilst it's
defending itself from an invasion it
sees as an existential threat
so the alliance is making no promises
yet a decisional membership of course
has to be taken by all third allies and
we take these decisions by consensus our
Focus now is on providing uh uh
immediate support to Ukraine to help
Ukraine defend itself against the
Russian brutal Invasion
inside NATO or out Kiev says it'll fight
on that liman in Northern and yet
Russian troops are surrounded and on the
verge of a local defeat Moscow says its
new acquisitions are Russian forever
Ukraine is trying to prove otherwise
Rory challenge Kiev